c'est la fin de saison de Pékin Express
alors comment ça s'est terminé au niveau
des audience pas de ouf pas de ouf 2002
c'est dans la fourchette
c'est pas terrible franchement pour moi
était déceptive mais elle a été sauvée
par les vainqueurs on va le voir mais il
y a eu des alliances qui ont gâché les
alliances sordides qui ont gâché le
plaisir des alliances
c'est un jeu télé calmez-vous tout va
bien aller en sordide il y a de l'argent
à gagner quand même il y a combien à
gagner on peut gagner 100000 €. ça
diminue ensuite mais moi c'est un jeu ça
m'a beaucoup énervé Benjamin mais je
vois alors ça a commencé assez mal à
l'émission puisqu'il y avait une grosse
tempête tropicale à Rio à Rio tout à
fait regardez vous êtes les grands
finalistes de cette 17e saison de Pékin
Express vous l'avez compris Rio affronte
une tempête tropicale d'une grande
ampleur
jamais des finalistes n'ont été
confrontés à des conditions c'est
difficile c'est le pays désagréable
certes mais elle va surtout
considérablement vous compliquer la
tâche pour le stop pour vous orienter
pour réussir à convaincre les gens ce
sera plus difficile que jamais je l'ai
personnellement jamais vu une finale de
Pékin Express dans de telles conditions
je pense ça va être particulièrement
compliqué de vous décourager jamais en
quelques secondes on est déjà trompé je
ne sais pas comment on va être dans deux
jours
c'est pas un chapeau un parapluie mais
ça prend de dire exactement
français
il est vraiment dans les vous rendez
compte après vous ressemblez quand vous
avez le cheveux comme ça qui coule
quand même
été excellent alors justement pour un
peu cajoler les candidats la preuve des
amis dans un bel hôtel avec une belle
suite et le le candidat Xavier était
très à l'aise absolument il était dans
son nom oui le patron et dans son
élément regardez première chose je vois
cette baignoire il faut que je me plonge
dedans j'y vais j'allume les robinets je
mets plein de mousse
et là j'ai la Gévrier
[Musique]
et là
ça fait pas grand-chose
de regarder mon patron prendre son bain
on discute comme si j'étais à la piscine
je t'ai jamais vu à la piscine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous êtes convaincu par
cette saison 8 non oui non oui non non
non
j'ai trouvé que les couples étaient pas
fallait les binômes étaient pas très
très fort moi je suis heureusement c'est
eux qui ont gagné c'était vraiment mes
préférés de loin pas trop employé je me
suis projeté je me suis dit tiens je
partirai avec Cyril à l'aventure
alors vous vous pourriez partir lui je
ne suis pas certain
alors venez bien vous moi j'adore Pékin
exprès je trouve que c'est un très très
bon jeu je trouve que les scores
d'ailleurs sont mal payés ils étaient
plutôt autour des 1 million 9 cette
saison il faut savoir qu'un énorme
engouement autour de cette émission
malgré les années qui passent puisque
pour la prochaine saison ils ont déjà
reçu plus de 30000 dossiers de
candidature donc c'est une émission que
les gens adorent alors ça serait
vraiment
si je peux terminer Pékin Express non
franchement c'est une très bonne c'est
une très bonne émission foireux stadé le
casting était un peu plus déceptif que
les autres saisons ils étaient 28
ménagères là ils sont plutôt à 20 21
donc si ça baisse
de la zone de risque quoi donc si ça
baisse comme ça c'est aussi lié au
casting qui était alors justement il y a
vous connaissez Alexandre et sherine
ils se sont embrouillés de ouf ils sont
trop mignons ils sont trop mignons mais
là ils se sont engueulés engueulés à mon
avis ils ont divorcé
gauche gauche
elle est là là mais oui maintenant il
faut attraper le crochet non tu bouges
plus Alex mais je comprends pas ce que
tu me dis je veux pas que tu montes pas
tant que je te dise tu lèves la canne tu
lève la viande là-haut là-haut là tout
là-haut là lève la là là c'est le fil
Alex que tu touches
-toi mais calme-toi
c'est trop dur
Jean-Michel c'est oui ou non parce que
je peux pas jouer de la flèche j'ai pas
vu un seul épisode
j'ai pas la télévision dans la bergerie
ou je suis donc je vois après quand je
rentre mais non mais j'aime pas le
concept parce que je peux dire voilà moi
je déteste que les inconnus qui vont
dans ma voiture m'insulte parce que je
vais passer vite donc ça je pourrais pas
mais autrement c'est le côté un petit
peu
colonialiste
mais moi cette saison en Amérique du Sud
pour le principe aujourd'hui
moi j'aime bien alors effectivement la
saison peut-être qu'il fonctionne un
petit peu moins bien mais il y a quand
même des duos des duos qui resteront
dans l'anthologie moi je me souviens les
frères belges ils étaient
extraordinaires qui étaient
30 ans ça oui c'était il y a longtemps
mais bon on s'en souvient encore et moi
je pense que c'est une émission qui peut
encore marcher effectivement ça dépend
vraiment du casting
ça fait ça fait longtemps à 17h sur M6
honnêtement les nouveaux concepts il y
en a pas tant que ça hein donc c'est
pour ça vaut mieux se rassurer avec une
avec une marque tout le monde connaît
que les téléspectateurs ont l'habitude
de regarder alors justement qui a
remporté cette saison voici donc en
images les images de la finale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a gagné Pékin Express on a gagné
Pékin Express
[Musique]
amis et donc on fait se tutoyer
donc il y aura une nouvelle saison
franchement la génial ça manque un peu
de panache tout ça
dépend des amulettes et que ça moi je
sais pas j'ai adoré je dois être là
vraiment la ménagère de base je regarde
ma singer je regarde
[Rires]
non mais je trouve que le casting
justement était vachement sympa et je
suis d'accord avec Gilles j'étais
tellement à fond dans le truc je trouve
que les gagnants là ont bénéficié de
d'alliance comment tu dis sinon
ils ont été privilégiés par les deux
campeurs là un moment donné
donc arrêtez d'en parler de ça
c'est personne